in totalitarian countries
one of the things that we Marvel at
is that the people are forced to perform
lies all the time when Kim Jong-il died
and you had major parades all throughout
North Korea to honor the death of the
great leader you saw those cameras in
all these North Koreans
perhaps some were moved seriously by
sympathy I kind of doubt a lot of it
though for many of them they were
performing it because there were guns
pointed at them and they they knew that
if they didn't cry enough over the death
of dear leader they could be tortured
they could be killed
your family could be killed
everybody has to lie this is true in
Stalin's Russia
and Soviet Union this is true in China
and this is now true
in the West
we are forced to lie too because our
government is increasingly totalitarian
it's a total state
it comprises everything